hi everyone my name is Dave Dugal I'm
the founder and CEO of Enterprise web um
excited to be presenting to you today I
know there's a lot of good speakers and
hopefully you'll find uh our
presentation relevant and compelling so
uh the topic is bis devops I I wrote up
originally as aligning the business and
it with graphs but I think of course
with graphs it's more appropriate to say
linking the business uh and it with
graphs and uh we're going to just
present uh how our utilization of graphs
and what motivates us and the
capabilities and ordan is uh that we
offer so first let me set this up in a
nutshell Enterprise web is a cloud
native integration platform iPass so
we're not a graph knowledge base that's
uh we have one we incorporate a graph
knowledge base it is a part of our
overall uh solution uh but we would
describe ourselves as a cloudm
integration really a cloud native
integration and automation platform so
the ipas category has s broad has uh
been broadly conceived as sort of uh
incorporating a lot of message oriented
middleware uh in a new modern Cloud
native context so Enterprise web is an
integration platform and the point of
Enterprise web and why it's relevant uh
to the graph communities is to radically
simplified data Centric event driven
distributed application design
deployment and management uh you know
and if anybody's worked in that domain
of uh you know working with all the
various Cloud native tool chains Kaa and
um you know Amazon Lambda and other
tools in the space they would know that
this is uh requires heavy heavy
engineering uh these things are
difficult even for advanced Engineers uh
working through issues like concurrency
asynchrony concurrency mutability item
potent these things are very challenging
for uh even the best engineers uh it's
challenging to do and it's usually done
on a one-off application basis so we're
offering a platform makes an event
driven applications uh model based event
driven applications uh easier to do
right and it leverages as I mentioned a
real-time graph connected operational
model and I think that's really an
important difference to call out right
away we're talking about an operational
model we don't call ourselves we're not
doing knowledge apps per se right we use
a knowledge graph we connect that to
graph objects in a business domain an
application domain and we use that to
essentially create a context aware
information system right so that we can
control the whole system through shared
domain semantics and metadata but the
intent the motivation the use is for
business
applications um so and the idea as any
of you working in the Enterprise or
large organizations know is that
organizations are becoming increasingly
fragmented did and creating an umbrella
abstraction over the top of their
distributed most dynamic it environments
is usually helpful to them uh we have
customers in life sciences and telom
when Awards an iot Etc so we've done
this in a variety of do domains so it's
a generalized platform or uh graph for
uh uh distribute applications so I saw
this I know EK the EKF presented
previously and ran a panel talk the
other day and I saw this on their
website and I hope they don't mind that
I I put it to here with the link and all
the proper representation here um and I
have to say I completely agree uh with
their uh maturity model the only thing I
would say
is that what they say is going to be
available in 2027 is actually available
today we enable this sort of graph
connected environment real time graph
connected environment to today and
that's again bridging that sort of
knowledge data and application data with
the intent of enabling the digital
business so you know as to the digital
business you know almost it's a very uh
vague term just like agile and all these
other terms used in the IT industry um
and it's been elusive 80% of businesses
want it um yet 5 51% of uh developers
and Architects that work on doing
digital business transformation say they
want another job that's a pretty
astounding statistic uh you know that's
from November 19th of this year so a
week ago a week or so ago um you know
that half of developers tasked with
actually realizing and achieving this
digital business um are going crazy they
need they need help they need they need
better abstractions they need better
tooling to make their job easy one of
the problems here I'm pointing out and I
want to make sure you know I realize
many of you focused on graphs and some
of you I'm sure on the operational
domain on the application domain many of
you are are more doing uh you know uh
research and knowledge graphs and
knowledge applications data science uh
so I'm trying to give some background
here so one of the one of the challenges
here if you see in the background of
this of this slide actually that diagram
is the cloud native Computing
foundations landscape diagram of their
vendors that's what they expect people
to deploy and it's pretty insane
um you know you're by the time you're
done integrating all those tools uh you
actually have a static Silo Solution
that's going to be super brittle
essentially it's almost like recreating
the old middleware stack so businesses
need to rationalize solution
architecture to bring order to the
increasingly fragmented operations and
of course our Solutions this is the
problem space and our solution space
which I'm going to focus on is uh graph
so there too many tools and uh too many
tools and silos and too little
interoperability and automation so int
needs a practical approach which
abstracts away this distributed systems
complexity it's just too darn hard right
it's uh it's it's engineering it's
architecture it's computer science uh
it's State Management it's me reliable
messaging this is hard stuff um and so
the solution is an Enterprise web a
real-time graph connected operational
model where we take the the business
Concepts uh types and polic IES that
Define a a business architecture or a
business at
large and we give it to you customers
out of the box we have essentially a
generalized graph domain so you're not
building this from scratch every time we
we provide a readyto use model that
includes all sort of cloud native comp
uh Concepts all the distributed systems
Concepts might call it 12 some people
work in that space we call it 12 Factor
all these um concepts related to working
with things like kubernetes and working
with events and working with messaging
that's all included in the system as our
generalized Enterprise Concepts people
tables um you know uh security
authorization organizational units all
the base Concepts that you would need to
start uh modeling your organization
already included and you could then uh
import your own models so whether you
have an rdf model a uml model model or
Json one of the world's largest telcoms
gave us a Json file that represented
their information model we uploaded it
did entity extraction algorithmic
mapping and we brought it into our graph
in seconds and these are very big
organizations with very complex graphs
and we're making that graph tractable
and transparent for them something they
could easily see and manage and then
that graph in Enterprise web this the
notion of the Enterprise web is we don't
stop at the the upper onology we don't
stop at the knowledge graph we actually
then model all solution elements are
essentially mappings to these Concepts
types and policies and when I say all
solution elements I mean not just data
access right this is not just a simple
little graphql toy we're talking about
uh something that is actually going to
uh take complex applications like a a
Cisco router uh to uh to or an AWS
Amazon Services endpoint uh or a
business process uh or some other
complex
artifact or an iot uh a physical iot
device uh and model those almost like
digital twins using these
Concepts and then we're going to give
the customers or are they're gaining
Global transparency and virtually
centralized management because no M
despite the fact that all the connected
elements might truly be heterogeneous
and they might be distributed we're
making them look as if they are the same
we're making them appear as if they're
all local um and we have these
representations of them these proxies as
it were these digital twins which they
can then use to manage and configure
with
metadata and it becomes then a single
source of truth because we're actually
uh because these are software objects
mutable software objects we're actually
logging all their state as well so we
actually state of all these objects too
so we can then use them in processes and
because we're bringing this all with
graph it's giving us is Dev Ops which
was the you know subject the title of
the talk right is an upper onology a
Knowledge Graph to model your
organizational Concepts and Technical
Concepts right so systems Concepts and
Enterprise Concepts and then a logical
space where you're mapping all your
elements and then the physical space the
Ops well at some point these all hit the
road right they're all residing on
databases or they're all residing in
systems or physical devices somewhere
and all those things have to be you have
to have access you have to do sechs and
offs connect to things integrate with
things you have to manage networking um
there's a lot of complexity that takes
to make that all easy to make things
simple is very complex right making very
distribut system simple is a very
complex task task it requires high level
abstractions and highle
programmability so uh with this graph we
essentially get uh essentially UDA Loops
many of you probably are familiar with
this concept the observe Orient decide
and act right because we have this
because we're a system event driven
system you can think of us as a cloud
native complex event driven system we're
going to observe events in our space
things that we're connected to we're
going to then impove corporate events
against this graph operational model
right and then we're going to make uh
we're going to translate policies using
metadata and uh relationships to uh to
make decisions and then we're going to
take actions those actions are going to
be a context enhanced and they always
going to be real time because it's an
event driven system everything is
happening in real time and the system is
managing the consistency transactional
Integrity Etc and when we say take ction
we're not just talking about integration
we're talking about integration
orchestration Automation and human tasks
so in a single click or a single event
we might be actually doing a thousand
separate
operations uh translating objects
connecting things um uh making decisions
and then we might be actually uh
configuring a Remote device or a remote
function we might be reporting through
the UI uh to a user uh and that's all
happening in unit real time so that's
autonomic control loops using
graphs so uh the scope of graph here is
different then right we're not just
talking data and functions we're not
just talking about data but we're
talking about data and functions not
just properties but properties and
behaviors metadata and state queries and
commands right we're controlling things
graph objects and graph process IES
right uh so we have uh our our objects
are dag dags graphs and our processes
are directed ayic graphs right so
everything is graph and Enterprise web
and that gives us some tremendous
computational power d a halfway point
perfect data integration and Service
orchestration uh graph transaction
processing and cloud data deployment so
we're literally using grass to support
off for one of the world's largest
telecoms where actually doing hybrid
multicloud uh support right where
they're actually using Enterprise web
onboarding really complex solution
elements that actually support uh things
like this like this webinar uh the
underlying technologies that support it
doing that in 4G and 5G and doing it in
a hybrid multicloud way where uh their
customers don't know where their service
is running they could actually uh it
could run in AWS or Google or or in the
telecom's own cloud or in Microsoft or
in IBM's cloud and the system is
handling all the complexity of
mitigating the protocols the formats and
even the service distinctions
configuration distinctions between those
environments so um so again high level
abstractions to enable high level
programmability so uh taking that back
down to Brass tax in Enterprise web
everything is graph object I mentioned
that uh all graph objects are mapping to
a common antology uh types Concepts and
policies mention that and they're
persisted as Loosely coupled immutable
typed self-describing software objects
with rest interfaces right that's you
know uh you know you know nice right
this is a very rich object with Rich
types these these are not uh simple
objects and simple types they're not uh
and the types are programmable as well
and and extensive
so these are not uh you know hardcoded
types um you know this is a system where
even the types are actually graph
objects themselves and all the typing is
dynamic typing so um and we're making
those complex things again as simple as
possible all these objects because
everything is an object in Enterprise
web that's an isomorphism so that gives
us common common objects give us common
methods that gives us common controls of
these objects because all these objects
look the same to the system we can apply
common policy management to all these
objects they're common uh common
governance common security um common
policy management uh they're all indexed
the same way they're all tagged the same
way they're all Version Control the same
way and they're com all of that is
attracted from the
user if you want to know if you want to
see how it's done it's it's visible to
the system owner but it's it's hidden
because at some level the person the
business application Level the business
user doesn't care business user just
wants a reliable
system so when we're onboarding things
or importing models or onboarding code
packages or authoring adapters for
components it's all the same approach an
Enterprise web because essentially it's
all going to be through a modeling
environment it's going to be through a
rest API or a Json based portal and
essentially we're going to create an
object template um and that's going to
interact with our type system
and the type system is going to interact
with the upper anology the upper anology
is going to validate the object it's you
know between the type system and the and
the domain Concepts is going to put
apply
validations and then it's going to
attach uh entities and implementations
to it
automatically so these are typed objects
regardless of what the object is if you
I can import a Word document in
Enterprise webble automatically
introspect That Word document do the
entity extraction do the algorithmic
mapping same for rdf uml XML or Json but
it's the same thing also if you give me
a code package right so if you give me
uh you know a function an app Business
application I can import that
application the same way I take that
code package the same way uh index it
tag it Etc and I can even allow you to
uh we can even enable you to author
adapters or things complex other system
components so it's you know it's an as I
mentioned it's iPad it's an integration
platform so it's built for extension
it's built to be open so even though
that the system is very comprehensive
it's not a closed system it's completely
open it can work in a very Federated
manner the system will generate
properties autofill parameters it will
also uh generate full-blown interfaces
we're not talking about Swagger to the
extent that people are familiar with
that which just creates stubs and then
you still manually integrate that
Enterprise web uh creates um under
specified interfaces and then uh does
all the bindings at runtime based on
context manages all of that for you so
it's a very interactive process all the
objects then persisted in a cloud native
backing store and uh as immutable
objects and this method of doing this is
essentially a model driven process
itself using the same system technology
it supports Version Control as well so
you can pass through your updates and
upgrades and it will version all of this
our uh we wrap all of our objects in
software contracts uh which provides
hooks for security governance and
compliance policies so um you I'm sure
I'll get a lot of interesting questions
in the Q&A I know I'm moving very
quickly but I I I really want to express
sort of the breath and richness of our
system to you um but the the idea again
is we're trying to give a system that is
both easy to use but also is responsible
and reliable right um out of the
Enterprise web deploys literally in
minutes as a cloud native platform
itself it's very lightweight it's
completely distributable and we want
customers to get uh value quickly so
we're providing all of these things and
we're enabling them then build out their
Solutions uh objects you know these
objects are wrapped in contracts and
then be declaratively composed right
once you onboard an object it goes to
that uh it's persisted in a catalog then
you can go to a catalog point and click
in the catalog or make references to the
uh the catalog and uh the system will
handle all of the integration for you
whether you're composing Services tasks
or
Aggregates again see that sort of the
notion crossing the boundaries between
the data space and the application space
the system is going to handle both of
those for you no manual integration the
system does all all the
binding likewise a process is just
another object in Enterprise web it's
just another dag object a directed
object
uh with a set of loosely coupled tasks B
Bound by conditions so the the physics
of Enterprise web the logic of
Enterprise web it's a it creates
something called homo iconicity right is
that uh objects uh and transitions are
the same thing in Enterprise web it
gives us this unified theory a unified
theory of types that allows us to um
again get a lot of process
optimizations uh tasks are all connected
by conditional links and it's all event
driven event asynchronous and
concurrent right so you know really high
performance and
scalable so the functionality that
Enterprise web is I just described how
we model processes as graphs and
customers can actually create other
processes and and essentially be
creating new capabilities in Enterprise
web uh but we Pro essentially gave you
out of the box all the sort of message
oriented middleware the common message
oriented middleware capabilities but
they're implemented as serous functions
they're all called on demand and
hydrated by the
graph again that makes the system very
lightweight very efficient very
scalable um and the graph is essentially
in control of the services right so we
have stateless serverless
functions and a stateful
graph this graph actually is hydrating
these services on demand so it's
following all the tenants of cloud
native
Computing uh and we maintain all the
scalability res resilience durability
portability of cloud native Computing
while creating high
efficiency um you know uh information
system um and this is what we would look
I'm just about to wrap up my slides here
now uh this is what we would look at the
application as an as an application and
you could see that we're Northbound or P
pointing in rest API or Json UI to
customer systems portals analytics AIML
now think how exciting that is for you
guys who are data scientists who working
in knowledge graphs well gosh we're a
fact model that you can reliably call on
through a Json UI or rest API and you
could import if you had the right
permissions you could introspect our
graph you can not only uh look at our
models you can actually look at the
runtime activity and also then our
system could then make calls to higher
level systems higher level analytic
systems uh for optimizations for broader
evaluations of State um so Enterprise
web you know one of the challenges for
the whole graph space is you know good
inference is uh supported by good facts
so we're a great fact model for great
inference models right rdf has its use
case semantic web has its use case this
is not an either or situation actually I
would say we're really complimentary um
and
uh uh
that is essentially wrapping up the uh
talk so how much time do I have Bill uh
you got about two minutes left on the
talk okay perfect actually I do actually
have another slid show here so so just
going more back into the into Theory
right so some of you are going to be
feeling familiar with tol's uh life
cycle information model and this notion
of you know it's again a maturity model
like just like the graph knowledge
community's maturity model and generally
uh most people are stuck down at the
level of syntactic technical
interoperability and Enterprise web is
driving people towards Dynamic and
conceptual interoperability that's where
you really want to be right and the way
we do that is that we're saying well
actually it's all software right so we
have a conceptual layer a logical layer
and a physical layer and all of those
really are models in Enterprise web
because we're going to bind actually
physical implementations those are
something the the physical
implementations are derived based on
interaction context in real time it's
the model space that we preserve and
care about right so uh Enterprise web is
actually ENT has is using the same data
structures the same graph object
construct uh the same methods for the
conceptual logical and physical
models that is an optimization then for
how we can process hyper
efficiently and you know use knowledge
graphs to actually do real time
applications and just for fun what does
that really translate to it's Turtles
all the way down recursive layers of
abstraction bis Dev Ops some of you
might be familiar with that that saying
Turtles all the way down but the idea is
that the the universe is be is uh on the
back of a turtle and that turtle is
standing on top of another turtle and
that turtle sitting on top of another
turtle and then when the conversation
asks what's holding that up that Turtle
you're supposed to say let's change the
conversation um uh but the idea is
that's recursive layers of abstraction
my name is Dave Jal I'm the oh here's
some article references for you uh if
you want I believe this deck will be
shared and hopefully these links will be
active get the decks um uh you could you
know obviously look us up and learn more
or simply contact me and we always be
delighted to talk uh demonstrate and we
of course just love talking about these
ideas we love talking about Compu
science and we love talking about grass
so thank you for your time today I
really look forward to your questions
I'm absolutely sure you guys won't be
shy I know many of
you and uh um and I hope you won't be
too rough
on well thank you Dave and yes indeed um
you already have questions from the
audience here
uh it's from J who's asking if it's
possible to make a distinction between
existing plant and deprecated
assets I'm sorry oh yes absolutely so
everything is everything is an object
Enterprise web all the objects have life
cycle management uh all the concepts in
the anology are objects they all have
life cycle management the ontology
itself is an object it's the set of
concepts of types and policies it is an
object it is life cycle managed so we
actually have something called the model
manager and the model manager actually
gives you a vehicle for the uh uh data
scientist or architect that is generally
running or owns the business
architecture let's say uh to go in there
control and then publish uh new versions
uh of the model um and so you can call
that a design time uh responsibility if
you'd like um and so the model graph
model is fully open and extensible
persable uh
navigable uh so that's that's a great
question though so everything is an
object all objects are Version Control
they're all indexed they're all tagged
they're all searchable uh again we're
working in the Life Sciences Telecom and
other General
Enterprises um you know telom is
considered one of the hardest Industries
to work in they haven't we in production
they haven't been able to break it um
and they've imported their own
information models and they manag it
that way and they've found it very
extensible so and they use us they use
it as an abstraction over other
Technologies as well so great
question I have a one as well which I
think is kind of related at some point
you mentioned that uh you treat objects
and transitions as the same thing uh
would you like to elaborate a little bit
on that because you know it's not
something I guess if you have software
engineering or technical B it's not
something you can R yourself your your
head usually around
yeah you it is I pointed it out because
I I think some people appreciate it it
is a it is a complex concept if you
think about it the more Transformations
you have to do in your pipelines other
than let me back up another step the
only thing that the business cares about
is their logic and the objects they have
access to we stop no one in the business
has ever cared about
technology it's a utility for them to do
their job that's it that doesn't mean
Technologies isn't important
so in that context the more
Transformations the more complex my tool
chains the more complex my middleware
stacks even a semantic web set the more
the more connections I have between the
things and the more Transformations that
happen through those pipelines and yes
you can do optimizations and things and
we clearly doing lots of Transformations
but really what you like to do is just
do transformations in and
Transformations out and you like to uh
you like to actually have your system to
be as unified as possible to do as many
things as possible under a common model
and so if you can actually have your
proc uh your process
models so so there's two things uh a
couple things a unified object model um
gives you uh common methods that's a
very powerful Concept in computer
science so just in general if if I make
everything look the same then I can
apply common policies and common
controls on it that's just Al even if
they're heterogeneous underneath that's
an abstraction that gives me lots of
power if I can do that both over uh
objects and I could do it over processes
that's even more power uh we had this
back in the main frame but the main
frame wasn't distributed the main frame
was had this kind of
isomorphism uh this kind of homo
ionicity but really it's just another
it's just an abstraction and if you
really want to look into it I'd
recommend uh my friend Milner who's no
longer with us rest in peace uh but you
know we like to think we on the
shoulders of giants stry Milner U Malone
um you know many many many of the Great
oh we like we like Fielding of course we
live like Tim burners Lee and uh de
mcginness and uhh Jim hler all those all
those folks we stand on shoulders of
giant Giants were particularly fond of
Milner Milner wrote the uh ml language
you know very close to those ideas but
his life's work was trying to unify
object Theory and process Theory and he
died not having completed it we
completed it we we created that he would
describe that as abstract rewriting and
transition Theory these are very
esoteric areas of computer science but
the bottom line is it's what gives us
the power to do what we
do okay well I have a tough choice here
I can ask you a very direct question
from from Jin or I can ask you a more
complicated question from me and since
time's running out I'm going to go with
a direct question from Zin who's asking
how much does it and are there several
packages with different levels of
capabilities and different
prices so it's actually super easy it's
one price it's based on your usage we've
partnered with the world's one you I
we're about to announce shortly that
we've partnered with the world's largest
cloud
providers it could run on premise it
could run on any cloud of your choice it
could run as a hosted service and uh you
literally are charged by your CPU or CPU
utilization and your number of users and
we've we've actually made it fairly
inexpensive um because we want customers
to like it and then we want it to scale
we don't want to put barriers uh in
between them and the sale and we don't
want to put barriers on them scaling it
because what happens with every one of
our customers is they tend to start
small because they're excited about it
but they want to start small start on a
single use case that maybe is a hard
problem and then they expand the
abstraction over more and more use cases
to generalize and take advantage of it
as a platform and that's what we want
you don't care if you start literally
using it for a single single application
or single line of business or single use
case it won't cost much to start at all
we generally start giving customers with
uh parties we generally do pilots anyway
those are generally at no charge we host
them we make them available the serious
interested part
so uh uh and all the objects that you
create on top of Enterprise web are
yours think of us as just being the
enabling technology if you create
objects in entprise web those are your
objects uh everything can be exported as
rdf or XML or anything else that you
want it to be um so uh we're not binding
you it's an open system it's meant to
enable it's not meant to hinder um we
really tried as the company's name is
Enterprise web we tried to align our
interest
with the Enterprise
interests thank you for that question if
there's time I'd love to answer that
hard question too because I I love them